[Aplausos]
un nuevo hito que se rompió con la
elección de kamala harris como
vicepresidenta del país
puedo ser la primera mujer en este cargo
pero no será la última
[Aplausos]
y que todas las niñas que los miran esta
noche ven que este es un país de
posibilidades en su histórica nominación
durante la convención demócrata de
delaware harris rindió homenaje a su
madre mamá de vencer el manchester miami
mi madre nos inculcó a mi hermana maya y
a mí los valores que marcaría en
nuestras vidas nos crió para ser mujeres
negras orgullosas y fuertes y nos crió
para conocer y estar orgullosas de
nuestra herencia y un día al ver en
jersey de padre jamaiquino y madre india
harry se educó en berkeley california
fue criada por su madre tras el divorcio
de sus padres
kamala y su hermana crecieron en un
barrio modesto tras elegir una carrera
como servidora pública
harris comenzó como fiscal antes de ser
ascendida a fiscal del distrito de san
francisco después hizo historia al
convertirse en la primera mujer fiscal
general de california luego derrumbó
otra barrera cuando se convirtió en la
primera senadora afrodescendiente por el
estado de california en washington sus
críticos señalan su historial como
fiscal
acusada de no haber sido lo
suficientemente dura contra la
brutalidad policial cuando ocupó la
fiscalía general y aunque su candidatura
a la presidencia no prosperó sus logros
impresionaron a su contrincante joe
biden quien la eligió como su compañera
de fórmula para muchas mujeres su
carrera es inspiradora
es una pionera es la primera mujer negra
que será nuestra vicepresidenta es la
primera persona de ascendencia asiático
estadounidense yo soy del sur de asia
ella es mitad del sur de asia ha sido la
primera en muchas cosas es muy valiente
en todos los sentidos y más novedades
podrían estar reservadas para harris su
experiencia como vicepresidenta la
podría convertir en una fuerte candidata
demócrata a la presidencia de eeuu